ja und wenn du twitter ansprichst da war
es jetzt nicht nur donald trump mit sehr
schwierigen aussagen sondern wir wollen
uns einmal ein tweet seines sohnes
anschauen denn dieser hat für richtige
aufruhr gesorgt er schreibt in seinem
tweet über darüber total workover
selection also die rhetorik er spricht
von dem totalen krieg überhaupt über
krieg zu sprechen wenn es um
demokratische wahlen im land of the free
gibt es ist erschreckend reicht man
nicht mehr als wort dafür oder also lese
ich fühle mich jetzt wirklich erinnert
an länder in denen despoten regieren mit
dem wort totaler krieg haben wir in
deutschland ohnehin ganz ganz schlimme
erfahrung gemacht von daher ist das
einen bug vokabular das glaube ich kein
deutscher verwenden würde auch nicht in
so einer auseinandersetzung da mögen das
andere länder anders sehen aber das ist
vokabular das spielt wirklich in
finstersten kapitel der geschichte und
das ein dass ein amerikanischer
präsident beziehungsweise sohn eines
amerikanischen präsidenten solches
vokabular benutzt es ist wirklich ein
totales no go das muss man einfach sagen
auch mit hinblick darauf dass man ja
schon vor der wahl die angst hat oder
vor der auszählung dass menschen es
könnte zu bürgerkriegsähnlichen zustand
in amerika kommen wenn die supporter von
trump vor allem mit waffen auf die
straßen ziehen und dann hören wir jetzt
krieg wie soll man sich vorstellen wie
die nächsten wochen ausgehen wenn joe
biden heute tatsächlich das rennen macht
ja es ist aufstocken das ist ehrlich
gesagt muss ich fühle ich mich aktuell
an weißrussland beispielsweise erinnert
an eine diktatur wie in weißrussland und
so hat man den eindruck läuft das in
amerika auch der präsident stachelt
seine eigenen anhänger unterstützer auf
leute wehrt euch richtig geht auf die
straße um dieses ergebnis dann was
mutmaßlich total legal zustande gekommen
ist anzufechten
das ist aufruf eigentlich zum
bürgerkrieg mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren